LEAKED SSNS:
Have you ever heard of a company called Equifax?
You might’ve seen their logo when applying
for a new credit card or taking out a car
loan or mortgage.
They’re one of the three largest credit
bureaus in the world alongside Experian and
TransUnion, and they’re in charge of determining
your credit worthiness.
Given their role in the market, I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that Equifax
deals with a significant amount of sensitive
data like name, age, date of birth, address,
phone number, annual income, and social security
number.
This has made Equifax a prime target for hackers
and cyberterrorists looking to commit identity
theft and credit card fraud.
Now, I’m sure that Equifax trys their best
to protect this information give that their
company’s reputation is on the line, but
unfortunately, their efforts weren’t quite
an enough.
In September of 2017, Equifax announced a
ground breaking data breach that affected
a mind boggling 147 million people.
And given the nature of their business, the
data being leaked wasn’t your cat pictures
or youtube subscriptions, it was your financial
profile.
It was the names of a 147 million people,
the date of births of a 147 million people,
the social security numbers of 146 million
people, and so much more.
This data breach was so large that if you’re
an American and watching this video, it’s
more likely that you were affected than it
is that you were not affected.
Here’s the thing, the US population stands
at 330 million people out of which 22.3% are
under 18.
This means that only 256 million Americans
were even capable of having data saved Equifax.
And yes, I know that teenagers under 18 can
have a credit card, but that’s extremely
rare.
So, out of this 256 million Americans, 146
million had their SSNs leaked.
In other words, if you were an American adult
in 2017 and had any sort of credit history,
there’s over a 55% chance that your SSN
was leaked through this data breach.
And even if yours wasn’t leaked, it’s
highly likely that you know someone who’s
was, and that’s just in America.
This data breech also affected 15.2 million
people in the UK and 19,000 Canadians.
But, how did such a catastrophic data breach
even materialize and what can you do if you
were affected?
DATA BREACH:
Taking a look back, the story of this data
breach dates back to December of 2016, months
before the breach took place.
At the time, a security researcher looked
into the servers and websites of Equifax,
and he noticed something strange.
It appeared that everyday people had access
to some sort of employee site, and you didn’t
even need credentials to login.
One of the portals on this site had search
fields and you could search through the personal
data of Equifax customers.
"All you had to do was put in a search term
and get millions of results, just instantly.”
And that was just the beginning of it.
The researcher also found that it was extraordinarily
easy to get shell access to several Equifax
servers.
Additionally, they also uncovered multiple
vulnerabilities such as SQL injection.
While these were all major security risks,
on the brightside, they were also very easy
to patch.
They could’ve taken down the employee portal
in minutes, and they could’ve patched the
server flaws within a week.
And Equifax even had the opportunity to do
exactly this given that the researcher reached
out to them and made the vulnerabilities clear.
But, as you would guess, Equifax didn’t
do that atleast not quick enough according
to the researcher.
This security researcher wasn’t the only
one that was tipping off Equifax either.
A few months later in March of 2017, the US
Department of Homeland Security would reach
out to Equifax regarding the need to patch
some of their software.
Given that this notice was literally coming
for the US government and not some security
researcher, Equifax would immediately take
action.
Just one day following the notice, Equifax
would notify their cybersecurity personel
about the need upgrade their Apache Struts
software.
Within just 48 hours, they would apparently
patch the bugs.
And about a week later, the security department
would even run scans to verify that the bugs
were patched, and the scans apparently revealed
no vulnerabilities.
But for some reason, none of these efforts
actually patched the bugs.
To be honest, it appears to me that Equifax
cared more about putting down on paper that
they responded quickly to the government notice
than they cared about actually fixing the
bug.
But, that’s just my own speculation.
Anyway, regardless of why the bug wasn’t
patched, the bottomline is that it wasn’t
patched, and this opened up the perfect opportunity
for hackers to strike.
About 2 months later on May 13, 2017, attackers
would begin accessing sensitive personal data
using this bug.
And it wasn’t just a one time thing either.
They would consistently access sensitive data
for the next 2 and half months.
And it wasn’t till July 29 that Equifax’s
security department would finally notice suspicious
network traffic.
Equifax would of course patch the bug for
real this time almost instantaneously, but
the damage had already been done.
PUBLIC BACKLASH:
Initially, Equifax had no idea about the magnitude
or depth of the data breach.
In the words of the CEO himself “I certainly
did not know that personal identifying information
('PII') had been stolen, or have any indication
of the scope of this attack.”
Nonetheless, Equifax would go ahead and get
their lawyers on board and follow their data
breach protocol.
One of the first steps in this protocol was
to complete a thorough forensic investigation.
And let’s just say that it didn’t take
long for this investigation to reveal some
terrible news.
By August 11, it was clear to Equifax that
this wasn’t just some small leak.
It appeared that the hackers had accessed
entire databases.
And the data being stolen was spread across
a multitude of datatables which made it especially
hard to link the stolen data with individual
customers.
This is one of the main reasons that it took
Equifax so long to publicly announce the data
breech.
But eventually, by September 4, the investigative
team would put together a comprehensive list
of 143 million victims.
And on September 7, 2017, Equifax would publicly
announce exactly what happened.
As you would guess, the reaction was not pretty.
Equifax stock would crater nearly 40% within
a matter of days.
And the public would become more aware of
the company than ever before.
Interest in Equifax literally exploded 20X
in the days following the public announcement.
But, almost as quickly as the drama unfolded,
the drama wrapped up.
By the end of 2017, interest in Equifax returned
to normal nonexistent levels.
The stock took longer to recover, but that
too would return to all time highs within
2 years.
In fact, since then, Equifax stock has grown
as much as 102%.
Somehow, Equifax has been able to live this
down with extremely low levels of backlash
from the general public.
And I think the main reason for this is that
the average person didn’t have strong opinions
about Equifax going into the drama.
Imagine if this same thing happened with Facebook
who people already associate with data intrusion.
We’d literally have riots on social media
even though the data leaked by Facebook would
probably be less sensitive.
This isn’t to say that Equifax didn’t
receive any backlash at all per se.
However, the backlash that they did receive
was rather short lived and people forgot about
it pretty quickly.
And given that the public wasn’t really
holding Equifax accountable, it was up to
Equifax themselves and regulators to take
action.
Much of Equifax’s leadership would either
leave voluntarily or be forced out.
Equifax’s Chief Information Officer, Chief
Security Officer, and CEO would all retire
within a few weeks of the public announcement.
It appears that these guys preferred to take
the easy way out.
In terms of the FTC, they would eventually
settle with Equifax for $575 million to $700
million depending on depending on how many
people claimed damages.
While this is definitely a hefty fine for
government standards, it’s not too bad from
Equifax’s perspective.
Afterall, Equifax makes more than that on
an annual basis.
So, they were only set back 1 year even though
they leaked the data of literally half of
American adults.
In the end, Equifax was able to get away with
a small slap on the wrist, but the same could
not be said about the victims.
THE FALLOUT:
Ironically, one of the first problems that
victims faced was due to Equifax once again.
You see, shortly after the breach became public,
Equifax created a website where people could
claim losses.
This was definitely the right thing to do,
but unfortunately, Equifax had missteps here
as well.
Instead of creating a portal under their official
domain, Equifax.com, Equifax decided that
it would be a great idea to create a new domain
just for claims called equifaxsecurity2017.com.
To this day, I have no idea why they decided
to do this.
Maybe it was to distance the claims from their
main website, I’m not sure, but what I am
sure about it is that this new domain was
a terrible decision.
First of all, it made it hard for people to
tell whether they were on the official website
or not.
And this led to the rise of several scam websites
with similar domains.
Even Equifax’s own support team was confused,
and at one point, they were directing consumers
to one of these fake websites themselves.
This is clearly not a great look, but on the
brightside, correctly claiming damages with
Equifax could result in a payout as high as
$20,000.
This initial claim window closed up at the
beginning of 2020.
But an extended claim window is still open
until January of 2024.
The average victim will obviously not be paid
anywhere near $20,000, but if you had any
sort of credit file in 2017 or before, it’s
worth checking it out.
You may be able to get a few hundred dollars
from them.
This compensation is of course not worth having
your data compromised, but there’s also
no reason to forgo claiming this compensation.
Also, you’ll probably get a much better
idea as to how much data was stolen from you
if any.
Aside from offering claims, Equifax also rolled
out a couple of goodwill programs shortly
after the fiasco.
For example, they offered victims free credit
monitoring services for four years.
Now, you might be saying, why would you want
to give Equifax anymore data given their history,
and that is a fair point.
But, you can look at it from a different perspective
as well.
Given what happened to Equifax, it’s likely
that they’re more keen on cybersecurity
than ever before.
They’ve apparently invested $1.5 billion
into technology and security since 2018.
So, you would hope that things are different,
but then again, Experian and TransUnion probably
also buffed up their security after this incident,
so it may be better to just stick with them
instead.
THE TAKEAWAY:
If we learned anything from this incident,
it’s that the biggest threats to our privacy
may not be as straightforward as Google or
Facebook.
Background financial companies like credit
bureaus, lenders, and underwriters have more
sensitive data about all of us than big tech
does.
Yet, they receive virtually no criticism because
we don’t interact with these companies on
a regular basis and them collecting this data
is seen as an essential part of their business.
But, the only way that we can get these institutions
to take on more accountability is by shining
the spotlight on them just like we have been
doing with big tech.
Apple’s “ask not to track” feature was
a gamechanger, and the main reason that came
to fruition is thanks to all the attention
surrounding big tech data collection.
If there was more attention surrounding the
credit space, consumers may get more choice
there as well.
For example, when we apply for a credit with
Amex, we might be able to choose which credit
bureau they use to run our credit.
By implementing such features, we may able
to prevent future instances of complacency
from occuring.
But, that’s just what I think.
Did you know about this massive data leak
from Equifax?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think these companies
need to be held more accountable.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.